I mean in pageantry I found for myself
has been very empowering and it allowed
me to step out of my comfort zone and
into an area that's very foreign
entertainment really but also it allowed
me to to find a sisterhood with a lot of
women and I think that's something that
I hadn't experienced prior in my life
it's a support network that you you
enter into and I think that was
something very refreshing you have very
interesting backgrounds that led you to
pageantry yes you were competing as an
athlete you did hope to compete for Team
GB until injury stop that yes you've
just graduated from burning the
university with a law degree yes he will
be scratching their head saying walk me
with all that behind you do you want to
go into ascension what people still
regard as a beauty pageant yeah I think
beauty pageants are still viewed with an
archaic eye is when I describe it as
because it has evolved so much in the
past decade that I think people haven't
really taken a glance back and seen the
way it has changed and I think it's it's
time that people we embrace pageantry
and say okay well this is a great
opportunity for women to empower
themselves and to feel confident in
their bodies has it really evolved
though because they still have a
swimsuit section yes and it's a parade
of women in bikinis and high heels
really necessary but I mean if you look
at women going to the beach in their son
in this swimsuit no one there's no look
no cry out about women going on to the
beach in their services there's no
problem and but it's not it's not about
judging judging a woman it's it's
actually you look at it from a different
perspective but for me it's it's it's an
empowering moment because I'm going
there and I'm saying this is me this is
who I am and you can either accept it or
you can leave it and that's been my
attitude throughout the pageant and I
think that's what most women they find
it very empowering because you don't
have to have a bikini body all you have
to do is have a body and put on a bikini
I'm being the first black winner of Miss
Universe Great Britain I mean you
weren't even aware that you were the
first
until you actually got the title and do
you feel a sense of responsibility with
that and did they ask you anything with
in relation to race and diversity which
is a topic at the moment in this country
you know I wasn't asked any questions
about my race before entering into the
competition or during because the
organizers were amazing but since then
realizing the I it's not mist on me the
importance of the role that I've now
been placed in and I do accept it
willingly because I think it's important
to be a voice for it but a diverse group
of people and the black community has
reached out to me you know the Asian
community everyone not just ethnic
minorities but everyone has reached out
to me and told me that they're very
proud of me and and they're proud of
what I symbolize for Great Britain and
and that to me is a very humbling
experience because you don't necessarily
go into these things expecting that kind
of response and it's been very you know
I've been very privileged I'm not
ashamed to admit it I'm a big fan of
love islands I know you are and they
have come under criticism in recent
series these perhaps changed this series
a little firm lacking diversity
everybody is white you know there are
there are some and people of different
ethnic backgrounds in it but the
majority are white with perfect figures
yes yes you do look at love island those
are going to love anything you say wow
that's interesting because they do look
like this your typical like coca-cola
bottle shape women and very muscular
because I think that the pressures both
on men and women from looking at love
Island because they feel okay as a man I
also have to be have to have a six-pack
and perfect teeth some of them have
pearly whites no so it's it's it's an
interesting interplay of a lot of little
things on the violin and I think
I think that's where you say there can
be other role models on TV you need to
counteract that message if that's a
message that's being sent to young women
or young boys so many millions of people
are watching it yeah I mean people
criticize it
yes but young and young young and
middle-aged yeah opportunity it is very
entertaining and I mean if if those
young people want to engage in that
program that's a choice for them but I
also do believe that it's important to
counteract the negative messages you
know and for us to take a proactive role
in counteracting the message that you
have to look perfect
well Deanna it's been an absolute
pleasure to talk to you congratulations
on your title thank you very good luck
in December and you've done wonders my
mom's always telling about the flash you
got the television but sitting opposite
Miss Universe TV
it's up youtuber on the telly we're on
the telly
they go Deann talking all things
diversity beauty pageant airy and love
island as well love to get your thoughts
on love island I'm obsessed with it but
a lot of people saying it spreads a
negative image these two have got their
own views we're finding out after the
break
Michelle GB and Angie Wilson they're
here to look through the papers love
island may well be in their finals last
night stay with us we're back in a
moment
[Music]
you